I think DM Advance just saying thank you
just being like Ty as a fan it's
everything it is think about anybody
right now that you grew up with
you I'll remember that for life for life
there's things you can control and
there's things that you're not you can
control reading your fan DMS and saying
thank you it's forever for them it
changes their relationship with you just
like an athlete everybody sees them on
Sunday playing football they don't see
they don't see getting their right
doing soft tissue work watching film
like every minute you got to give back
to fans I'm telling you that will
paint different
like Grateful Dead and all those people
that did it back in the day they had to
do it hand-to-hand comment they didn't
have this you could just do it on
the flight home
High touch touch as many fans as you can
I promise you it will work